welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with a case that
gripped and divided america today marks
10 years since the death of trayvon
martin the unarmed black teenager was
shot and killed by neighborhood watch
volunteer george zimmerman during an
altercation the ensuing trial in which
zimmerman was acquitted of martin's
murder raised questions about race and
law enforcement and was the beginning of
the black lives matter movement to
observe the anniversary tonight cbs
presents trayvon martin 10 years later
mark strossman has a preview
local 6 news starts now
with a sunday night local news story
officers were called to the twin lake
town homes in sanford last night trayvon
martin's legacy almost died the night he
did the man had been shot and killed the
shooting suspect surrendered to police
near orlando a neighborhood watch
volunteer called 9-1-1 to report a
suspicious person this guy looks like
he's up to no good that guy was
17-year-old trayvon martin heading back
from a convenience store doing nothing
wrong
are you following him
yeah okay we don't need you to do that
but george zimmerman that neighborhood
watch volunteer confronted martin
anyway he showed police later how they
fought on the ground he just kept
slamming and slamming and losing the
fight he fatally shot the teenager
i felt his arm going down to my side and
i grabbed it and i just grabbed my
firearm and i shot him
days went by no arrest
police said florida's stand your ground
law protected zimmerman's claim of
self-defense
tracy martin trayvon's father remembers
we had an admitted killer we had the
actual weapon but we didn't have an
arrest outraged outraged at that point
due to the sense that anybody cared no
no attorney ben crump represents the
martin family
and
literally they were saying to me
okay
being a
black kid got killed
that
happens all the time in america
we're so significant about this
my kid went to the morgue and this guy
went home and went to sleep in his bed
there's no justice in that
martin's family was in disbelief and i
remember we did the first national
interview with you mark strauss and cbs
because you all were the first people
who
said you would do it and i'm we are
grateful eternally for that it was just
painful to to see that there had been a
killing of a young black unarmed
teenager your son my son and there was
nothing being said or done about it
trayvon trayvon trayvon martin right
away
more news outlets reported the story
pressure built on police who do we watch
florida's governor appointed a special
state prosecutor
a national conversation exploded about
racial justice
within three weeks he's a household name
yeah social media was starting to
take hold and they all hashtag trayvon
martin life matters lebron james and the
miami heat they put on the hoodies and
they said we're all trayvon and then
they had this thing called the million
hoodie rally
sabrina fulton trayvon's mother this is
president obama has made his own
concerns very clear in very personal
terms even in the white house trayvon
martin's name inspired soul searching
how on earth could a young teenager
walking down the street eating skittles
minding his own business
end up dead
how does that happen in america
valerie jarrett former president obama's
senior advisor
a month after the shooting she remembers
him telling staff in the oval office he
wanted to talk about trayvon this was a
very personal decision
he made to try to lift up this story and
make it a teaching moment
you know if i had a son he'd look like
trayvon
all of us and what president obama
wanted to do was to broaden the reach of
that statement to reach all americans
not just falcons
[Music]
it's amazing to think 10 years it is
about a right
it's not about a black and white thing
it's about a right and wrong thing and
that's what it's always been about it's
so much sorrow and this collective
sorrow and the channeling of that sorrow
and demanding change i mean looking back
at that it feels like it was just
yesterday it's hard to believe it's
continuous one of those moments that
always stuck with me then and still does
now is listening to that 9-1-1 call when
george zimmerman called and said i'm
following him and they said yeah we
don't need you to do that
we don't need you to do that yeah i was
down with mark covering it um
and it was still uh it was such an
emotional time covering the trial and
then the reaction
when george zimmerman was acquitted yeah
it was tough for a lot incredible
powerful reporting by mark strassman and
all of our teams trayvon martin 10 years
later can be seen tonight on cbs news
streaming at 8 eastern you can also see
it tonight at 10 eastern on the
smithsonian channel and on b-e-t on
monday night at 8 eastern